welcome to this video this is a new part
in wepa sewed of the series of viewer
games analyzing your games yeah and this
is a game where our viewer is playing
the black pieces and that was kind of
our young should I show that from his
perspective and I decided to do that
normally for analysis videos I just go
for the white side as it is normal
itself and diagrams have the right on
the bottom but it's our viewers game so
we'll look at it from his perspective
this game was played online a 15 minute
game with 10 second increments so keep
that in mind it was a rapid game it
wasn't a classical time control game but
it was very interesting it had many um
instructive moments so I decided to show
that despite the somewhat quicker time
control compared to classical chess um
yeah of your s name's marvin so i'm
going to have to have the name and he
didn't mind you have his name in there
and the level of the players are kind of
hard to tell because it was online chess
but Marvin has a German rating or 1400
which is probably bits on the lower side
because he only has that based on one
tournament so it's pretty new to
tournament chess and probably he is a
bit stronger and his opponent is at
least on this server where displayed on
is about the same rating so we're
probably talking about fifteen sixteen
hundred range let's get going it was an
e-form opening and Marvin goes for the
caro-kann defense okay d5 and white here
took and played see for the so-called
panel tech named after think of Russian
GM right maybe not the GM at the time
Palm off and sometimes it's called panel
of blood vinegar check because but
winning also use this quite often he
like to play with the isolated pawn yeah
and this is an important thing will see
for very often we will get an isolated
queen porn
after black takes on c4 or white takes
on d5 white will have the isolated Queen
pawn black normally plays Knight f6 in
this position Marvin went 96 it's it's a
good move develops a piece I'm on a on a
very theoretical level right now can
take on d5 Queen takes an idea three and
transpose to a somewhat favorable
version of the c3 Sicilian this sounds
can do wacky but this is a position that
can also come up from a c3 Sicilian just
to show what kind of funky
transpositions you sometimes have and
you recognize this is absolutely the
same position and it's considered to be
somewhat favorable for white and so 96
is slightly inaccurate nothing special
but it is slightly inaccurate you want
to start with Knight f6 here so that
after a capture now you can very nicely
take with the night but not a big deal
okay white played Knight f3 just
developing and Marvin played Bishop g4
yeah good move pinning the night again
white could think of cd5 but he didn't
he just developed with Knight c3 yeah an
interesting moment because here this pin
is a very important factor in this
position if black takes at any moment
white has to think what happens Queen
takes 94 can be tricky with the fork yet
let's say this kind of thing no it has
to be taken into account here why it has
the community one by the way so this is
not a big problem but this idea that
black might take here and remove this
defender of the form is in the position
so black went Knight f6 this is good and
now we transpose back to a very popular
main line of this opening right now
normally place a move see takes d5 which
initiates a sequence that is almost
forced after queen bee three
attacking that was a weird kind of arrow
construction attacking here this night
after which black normally takes on a 3
and e cigs is played this is a normal
line which is fairly complicated why can
take b7 and so on I think actually that
white maybe has seen this at one point
and just confused move orders a little
bit he played queen bee three
immediately instead of taking on d5
first and here our viewer had a chance
an opportunity he could have taken on f3
after G takes Knight takes black wins an
important tempo here on the Queen and
the text f3 and c2 so the night is a
very well positioned on the form and
wide really has no way to justify let's
say Queen takes b7 because after this
kind of sequence we will get the rug in
the corner and this is not enough that
white has for it black is in a very good
shape here because white has to return
like here and then we play e5 or take
here with a pretty good position we have
one upon and have no particular problem
what Marvin did was he went night a five
which is also looking very very logical
actually the only problem with it is
there's one specific line that white can
play that is good for white probably but
it's super difficult to see in fact I'm
pretty sure that many super strong
players wouldn't sports the problem with
Knight a5 so it's really nothing to be
ashamed of them in any way white white
had the opportunity here to play Queen B
5 check a line that move that looks
completely bonkers because after Bishop
d7 where is your queen going yeah
they're only square that the Queen has
or squares are be four and see c5 and if
you move it what is the point yeah
getting the Queen in this trouble yeah
black
even coming with tempo the problem is
that white has the amazing resource CD 5
that's a that's really great what can
sacrifice the Queen yet after Bishop
takes Bishop takes check 97-95 white
will get something back here on d7 and
pluck really has big problems the Queen
has nowhere to go and how do you
actually keep your queen if you go queen
bee six for example 97 is going to come
and this is getting ugly with all kinds
of discoveries a very funny tactical
line and in many cases let's say black
just plays rook c8 then white will just
shake and get the Queen back and he will
stay with an extra pawn this is a
somewhat weakish double porn but it is
an extra porn yeah very funny line that
probably was not considered them in the
game and really know yeah no shame about
that it's very difficult to to get this
idea even to give the check on v5 the
white player just stepped back to see
two after which everything is is back in
order for black Marvin now just took on
c4 which is a good move not bad at all I
would have preferred actually to make
sure to kill white structure immediately
and take on f3 it's simply what we want
here the night the Knights taking this
night is really the only big role that
this bishop has so it should take on f3
and damage the pawn structure we see
that in the game somewhat later it's
just a matter of move or I would want to
make sure that wide really has this bad
structure so like this and now black can
take on c4 what he did in the game
immediately like with the pawn or with
the night at both them comes into
consideration and we would see the
structure that happens in the game it's
just that I would want to make sure that
the double point is appearing he took
with the night
takes takes for example me not that this
is a brilliant move but 95 is a
possibility here trying to avoid them
the further doubling of pawns and trying
to play a pawn down here it looks very
unattractive but this is actually better
than what happens in the game in the
game white played Queen a4 check Queen
d7 and Quincy for getting his phone back
he wanted to have equal material yeah
and now our viewer took on your three
good move GF andy sixx we want to
finally develop their fate bishop this
is a very important moment to take stock
after 12 moves here what about this
position after the opening we have equal
material first thing to check but the
pawn structure is very very favorable
for black if we check this typical porn
island count want to check how many pawn
islands there are black just has to pawn
islands he has got this let me unmarked
this Bishop he has got one island on the
kingside four points and two points here
on the queenside and they're very much
on the original squares which is
normally the most idea the best way to
have it most idealist nothing that's
really working right it is the ideal way
normally to to place the pawns because
they don't give up any squares or
weaknesses quite often the initial
position is good and these six of course
is needed to get the bishop out look at
white white side is totally different
what you'll need is basically consisting
of weaknesses only this is an island
this is an island another one and
another one so we talking about four
pawn islands vs. 2 and the pawns are
especially if we look at deform the
double porn h2 they're all week a
typical problem coming with a week pawn
structure is not so much on that the
horns themselves are so weak that they
will fall it happens but a big problem
also a weekend squares because if you
have pawns on original squares if you
look at these pawns for example they
don't give up any squares yeah like age
six g6 f6 everything is covered it's
very nice there are no kind of yeah weak
spots that the opponent's pieces might
use but this is not the case with the
white structure d5 is the typical
weakness in front of the iqp black might
place a piece on d5 that cannot be
attacked by a pond and there are more
like f5 now if the Pawn wouldn't be
doubled you have to worry about g4 at
some moment not not anymore this is a
safe spot for a black piece yeah or on
the H file age 5 h 4 h3 all those
squares are weakened by the bad porn
structure in if you sum it all up black
already has a very substantial advantage
and can think about the future with them
with much confidence let's see what
happens white plays Bishop e3 that's a
good move yeah we have to develop at
some point rook c8 of course we take a
temp oh that's good Queen went back to
be three that's also a good square what
the Queen wants it wants to at least
control d5 a little bit yeah going back
to let's say me2 in comparison would be
much much more passive so this is a good
good move black plate Bishop to e7 yeah
completing development preparing castle
all fine very good game so right now
when for somewhat somewhat shocking move
which it would have surprised me quite a
bit but it is in a way understandable
what would why did he casts a long it
looks a bit a bit crazy castling right
into the sea file but I understand that
he was probably kind of desperate with
his bad structure and wanted to somehow
get get something going he probably
didn't want to cancel short because he
felt that his King side is rather weak i
think in comparison why probably should
cancel short the thing is that the game
will probably happen mostly on the
queenside and the King position it's not
that big of a deal because blacks pieces
are pretty far away from actually
arriving near the king so I think
probably I would have preferred short
canceling here but it is already a
pretty pretty thankless task to play
this position in fact what black would
do is pretty comparable to what we see
in the game just with the King on the
Kings side instead of the queenside yak
essence as mentioned was played long
castles yeah okay I agree with the next
move 95 this is the the square we want
in King be one getting out of the sea
far yeah check like not took their and
wide we captured you can ask is this a
good trade on c3 isn't this
strengthening White's pawn structure not
really if we look at this we start at a
for Ireland structure and it will check
stay a for Ireland structure one two
three four with this transformation we
just have changed the pawn structure but
it has not really improved a lot what
however happened with Knights is free bc
3 some things in terms of weaknesses
have changed for example here see form
has become an additional square weakness
white does not have any piece that
naturally controls this square like a
light squared Bishop for example on e 2
or d3 that looks at this square it is
kind of weakish and can use by flex
pieces a rook a queen we have quite a
lot of pieces traded already and night
would be brilliant on c4 but ok there
are no nights on the board anymore so
the trade on c3 has not really improved
why it's positioned a lot the
in fact is quite often the case if you
out of an IQ p position if you look at
this black plates against isolated pawn
that's nice very often you can take on
c3 in this case or c6 if it is a colors
reverse situation you can very often
Jack take them and just yeah initiate a
transformation of the structure which is
still favorable it's just something that
is kind of it is changed it's not it has
not worsened blacks position at all
however the next move is some mistake by
our viewer here a kind of probably not
very obvious mistake but it is one at
the very instructive one actually if we
look at this position and we ask ourself
what is why its idea what has white left
there is actually not that much but
there is one idea that white has at the
moment what is somewhat better developed
a little bit yeah he's got Bishop out
Queen out he is castled and he has a
roof in the center of the board on d1
black has not castled yet he is somewhat
a little bit behind in development what
only real opportunity in this game is
actually to try to make use of his
slight lead in development and the only
way to do that is the move d4 d5 black
in this position if he has a little bit
of time on his hands we should always
keep in mind that this was a rapid time
control game what black should do it
should ask himself okay what are the
opponent's counterplay ideas the thing
is in a position that is so favorable
from a structural point of view because
pawn structure is better we have even
longterm the better King because after
short castles our King will be safe
while the White King won't be ever
really save on the queenside so long
term we are in great shape we have to
make sure nothing short term is
happening where we are kind of behind in
development and d5 as mentioned is the
idea
black has a strong mafia to completely
make sure that this is the idea is not
happening he could have played the move
Bishop f6 yeah so then after d5 he can
take on c3 with the rook and this
renders d5 yeah just a complete mistake
I cannot play it here so black could
have played this prophylactic move and
prevent it d4 d5 from happening the only
thing that at the moment looks kind of
awkward is maybe queen adria preventing
castling but black can just play a move
like a queen to d5 and centralize the
Queen the black king is not in any
danger with Queen d5 we are also
watching over C 4 so that porn cannot be
pushed and white can really not afford
to take after castles we are threatening
ruka 8 and we will get a really really
strong attack on white skin so black ian
had to ask himself what is the opponent
threatening another way to deal with
this threat of default d5 what's the
move between d5 this is a less dynamic
way to do it and also somewhat less
convincing after takes pawn takes black
still has an advantage but it is not as
pronounced as earlier because we have
created a weakness on defy for ourselves
it is not is it so easy to attack but in
general we want d5 as a square for peace
that stays there it's not that the piece
that thought getting traded so Queen d5
was a pretty yeah a bit too simple way
to play what he did is he played Queen
c6 the idea is not bad it takes one pawn
and the second porn but it didn't really
address the idea d4 d5 white now had the
opportunity but did not take it he had
the opportunity to play d4 d5 what we
should mention by the way is that the
move castles is also not bad just start
with castles why should still
d 5 takes Queen takes and hope for is
activity I know that his structure is a
complete wreck but you have to try to
play actively with your pieces here if
you just sit around with this rotten
structure you're going to get yeah
ground down in the end game this is
something that white has to try it needs
to set problems for examples in this
position after castles d5 ed Queen d5 if
black plays Queen takes d5 changes
Queens white all of a sudden is
completely okay yeah he can vary vary
with with some justification hope to
draw this because one porn hangs rook d7
is coming he has a temporary activity
and he has chances to draw this it won't
be fun but it it is this is a very
serious chances if you want them a
computer evalia if black is playing this
prophylactic move Bishop f6 it is like
more than one pawn according to to the
engines and in the position after
castles d5 ed Queen d5 this is just a
very slight advantage after the Queen
trade 0.3 or something like that black
can play Queens is 7 by the way you
should keep the Queen's on because this
is a problem white sir can fight Queen
d7 and so on it's what he has to do in
the game after Queen c6 he played a
passive movie played to move f4 well
passive is maybe a wrong word he maybe
had f5 in mind but it's not addressing
the most urgent matter like opening up
the position for your pieces so castles
now rook see one yeah asset necessity if
you go d5 now takes Queen takes black
just takes you three yeah fantastic and
black is winning here the pawn and an
attack on the king so why it was almost
forced to play this passive
yeah and here we count to a very
instructive phase of this game black has
a very nice structure as mentioned a
couple of times White has all pawns also
on dark squares with this dark squared
bishop which is looking a bit like a
head taller pawn and of course black is
better but how do we how do we play what
Marvin DTM wasn't bad he kept he kept
his advantages but he didn't really
build up on it and increase his
advantage which was possible what black
should do em is think about the general
plan that we have that we going to
follow we want to blockade on the light
squares d5 and see for those porn those
are squares are immensely week from
White's point of view yes absolutely no
controller with over those and we want
to place our pieces there ideally rooks
if you imagine look here and rook here
would be very nice yeah they can swing
over to f5 to a form you know they can
be used sideways so we want to secure
those two squares this is this is an
especially favorable kind of version of
this structure because white has
absolutely no piece left to control them
yeah it's completely completely bare on
the light squares so we want to make
sure that white is absolutely never
going to push this to make sure that c4
is not used or d5 is controlled so black
should play the move b5 here and that's
a very instructive moment if black plays
b5 with stopping this in its tracks what
is never going to play C for now and our
plan is long-term rube d8 rook t5 rook
c4 and then finally push those pawns
trying to automatically get a king-size
attack or wrong a king attack attack on
what's on white skin this is the the
general plan that black should go for
and it starts with the move b5 fixing
those weaknesses is a very important
term that that you always should keep in
mind if
opponent has weaknesses and here it is
those squares and this pollen see free
we should always make sure that they are
not running away which should fix those
weaknesses so b5 is very strong and in
fact in the next couple of moves almost
at any moment the move b5 was strong
here for example after Luke FD 8 there
was a moment where white could think of
the move c4 it is in fact not
particularly good but it was possible
and maybe why it should have played the
move simply to get rid of this is this
very unfavorable structure it is
basically failing due to this move but
this is something that black actually
has to find after Bishop takes Queen g4
check something like that black has
sacrificed in exchange but the bishop
coming to f6 will be fantastic for black
so this is the case where we trade
advantages we give up the exchange for a
fantastic attack but why did not play in
the movie form he played rook g1 trying
to do something on the G file but in
fact there is not much to be earned them
yeah Black's King is totally safe yeah
note that the typical castling structure
is a very safe structure it has not
given up any squares any weaknesses
while White's king is kind of Airy
should like give the check which is not
hurting him but again b5 was the move
King a1 and b6 yeah I wanted probably to
make the screen mobile but again set up
with b5 was better King be too yeah he
has c4s answered by Bishop f6 and black
is crashing through King b2 and rook c7
it seems that black hair our viewer
didn't have a completely clear plan and
the plan is always be 5 fix the
weaknesses Roxy for and ultimately open
up the position
looxcie to was played group dc-8 he
wanted to pile up on this pawn it seems
rock here and rook c4 that's a very good
move putting the rook they're protected
by the other look on CA to make sure
that this pawn this weakness is never
moving this is actually accomplishing
now the same thing as b5 did earlier
Queen B 5 and here we come to a very
critical moment of this game yeah like
actually has what he wanted and he took
a little bit more time than was
necessary as mentioned with b5 it was
quicker but we have the perfect locating
situation now that we wanted white is
completely out of any active ideas if we
look at this what is white going to do
if we play let's say a simple
strengthening move let's say g6 a
strengthening the structure or maybe
also Queen back to be 7 those kind of
moves the position will be excellent for
us a 6b five be 4 will ultimately come
opening up the position against the king
maybe g6 is the move to be preferred the
computer actually suggests a very strong
move but that's not so easy to find the
engine suggests a 6 which is a tricky
move because if white takes Queen c6
will set up a very nasty Queen trap what
is however definitely to be avoided is
the move that mob in place and it's a
very instructive mistake and one of the
reasons why I picked this game the other
reason is that it's very nice to see the
structure here from white and see how it
is exploited by black if black plays
with b5 it's very nice he however played
Queen c6 and this is a very substantial
mistake from one reason the White King
position White's King is just weakened
this in this situation it is a long-term
liability due to the completely wrecked
pawns
sure White has no porn cover for the
King anywhere on the board you can place
the King wherever you want never it's
never going to be save anywhere in fact
relatively speaking b2 is not such a bad
spot because there are so many pieces
near it but long term this king is never
safe contrary to black skin which is
totally safe so you absolutely don't
want to trade queens and this is what he
did he played Queen c6 and now Wyatt
trades and if we look at this position
now we see that we have an end game with
Queens traded and here all of a sudden
the White King is where it wants to be
it is they're protecting a weakness at
least Black is still better but he has
given up a large chunk of his advantage
because he had an advantage due to
structural terms but also due to the
dynamic factor of the bad King position
this has now been resolved for what he
does not vary anymore that his king is
getting checkmated he is still sitting
on this bed structure but he has some
hope and the King even might be useful
on the queenside we will see some of
that in the game white played queen bee
three and sorry King b3 of course and
again black should play b5 it's like a
broken record but this is probably an
important thing that our viewer can take
from this game you want to use the pawns
yet to make sure the weaknesses don't go
away yeah also a move like b5 makes this
rook mobile yeah we still would want
rook t6 d5 pawn a six and then maybe use
the king yeah many endgame types are
very favorable for example a minor piece
and gamer with the very bad bishop only
three okay he didn't do that he played
Bishop to d6 age three white rose may be
worried about the age to pawn and now f6
he wanted to go f65 that is an
interesting plan actually in fact this
is a plan that
would have been much stronger in
comparison with Queens on the board
because it opens up the position he
wanted we will see him he wanted to do
this and he did this I mean wrongly
phrased we get to this situation again
we have a pawn Island count of four
against two it is favorable for black
but the pawn the the overall pollen
count is down to four and this makes
winning the game always more problematic
for the site with the with the advantage
this is not always and they are always
it can accept exceptions and chest but
trading too many pawns can often be
tricky at the end you just have one
point left it's a draw not so easy yeah
here the main weakness is to see if upon
and why does kind of defending that okay
with the King now helpful on b3 again
black it still is better of course with
the structure but it gets very very
difficult now from a technical point of
view plus there is this one rook g4
interesting moment on here Marvin
decided to take this rook on g4 which is
something that has to be we are
considered carefully because it improves
wide structure yeah the pfm what
structure has now improved those two
pawns a little bit less a weakness than
H&F porn however he had an idea with
that I think I probably would have
preferred to move the rook away like a
look for to c5 but they are not sure
there's an interesting idea his idea is
the following he wants to get a passed
pawn with age five now their age porn
and this is something that really really
went yeah and plan that was rather
successful in the game as we would see
g6 and now I played the move Bishop to
e3 which is a candle under this is not
doing very much it's almost a pass move
um however we should never forget that
this was a rapid game and
by the way the times displayed here are
just yeah dummy times from from the
software here it's not what the actual
game had on the clock what why should do
here he should think about ok what is
blacks plan blacks plane was g6 is some
kind of clear he wants to play age five
get a passer and why should try to fight
against that with Roxy one trying to
swing over the rook immediately if black
plays age five now white can take and
attack this pass porn and with check he
keeps that in in check here you
blundering have to be careful probably
it will end in a kind of repetition here
yeah note that it's a matter of time
what has to be quick to hide the porn
and in the game he didn't do that he
played bishop oops sorry played bishop
ii III essentially wasting a move this
is not any better only three then on d2
and black started to run with the pawn
very nice no white has to worry about
that see for a draw hmm it gets
dangerous yeah why damn at some point
now has to take care of this pawn and he
simply waste is the ways wastes more
time here you went when deaf for I think
it's probably preferable to to do it
like that and to at least have this base
for the bishop but it's it's very tricky
now the H point is very dangerous black
has a substantial advantage Bishop t6o
gauge to Bishop e7 keeping this pawn and
black asses idea putting the rook behind
the porn and then advance with the king
very nicely played right now went Bishop
f2 i think i will probably tried f5 but
i'm not sure that it saves anymore
White's position as mentioned is highly
critical the H point is dangerous and
the black king is near the action while
White's king is somewhat away um white
really should have tried to fight them
the passer earlier it's very often the
case that you want to find a passport as
quickly as possible as early in its
advance as possible the more forward it
pushes the more difficult it gets to
manage as the defender in the game he
went Bishop f2 and Bishop age 6 and this
now is probably winning form like it's
probably not defensible he tried drew
cage-free this is not helping very much
but difficult to give any advice it's
not helping because the King advances
it's probably even winning a tempo on
the rook but it's it's probably too late
to be honest route 83 King is six kings
III King f5 and black just took this
yeah important little the chain is that
here we counter check the rook very nice
f4 GG father removed Bishop c5 check and
a check yeah now the final critical
moment of this gameand here Marvin wrote
that he had absolutely no time on the
clock playing on on the increment and
this is not not an easy easy business
especially if you're not a super
experienced player yeah if you watch
them guys like let's say a roni on agree
sugar so they have like a two second
increment they still sit down just like
I don't know having breakfast or
something and then just dash out moves
in two seconds but it's not not so easy
to do and now black made a mistake the
Imam and played to the king f5 instead k
i5 the problem was that now Roop takes
h4 as possible and where this is hanging
but this rook is also hanging
and essentially this is what's giving
away the pawn for no particular
compensation there is now some kind of
trade happening in in the game it's
unfortunately it's a total draw and what
you had to do is after the check yet to
move to a different square that just
keep the h-bond so both king h3 or king
g5 would've won yeah King g5 is maybe
them the simpler way to do it because
you don't obstruct the path of the age
pawn here white is really an yeah what
is lost there is nothing that you can do
if he takes that same he is really now
forced to take care of the edge pawn and
this is only the temporary stop like
it's just coming up or you will get to
the sea for porn and pick up more
material i am like this this here here
and all at finally oops come on finally
we'll get check we get to those pawns
and pick them all up with the rook
behind the pawn the the rook endgame
here is very very simple very simple win
so just the lapse of concentration that
unfortunately cost this win yeah after
to check kick f5 through cage for
there's really nothing nothing to play
for I just have one little remark after
that it's unfortunately a draw but I
think that probably hear black each made
roop t6 check um and I think probably
black should be should just take this I
think this is actually an easier way to
draw the game and then go over with the
king in them in the actual game it
wasn't really a problem but if we look
at this here this is already a little
bit uncomfortable for black the white
rook is more active what has no way for
but it is a draw but it's probably a bit
safer to em to eliminate eliminate the
rooks here
you just have to yeah it's a shame that
you have to play the draw now or go for
the draw and try to get it as safely as
possible yeah unfortunately just the
draw after a really good game actually
what black can can take here the kind of
key moments is for for future games is
that you want to fix a structure safely
fix a bad structure the idea to play b5
is very very essential here to keep
those pawns fixed and in this particular
case with the King on be too this would
even lead to probably lead to a nice
attack on the King a very important
moment was here you don't want to trade
Queens here because long-term White's
King would be the weaker piece or the
weekend the wicked king and a real
factor here in the end game the Kings
active position here on b3 is useful of
course he protects a weakness black
still better but he has given away some
part some chunks of his advantage yeah I
hope you enjoyed this game I think it
was a nice um and shot some nice
strategic points that are important
especially timing of a queen trade is
very very important maybe we should
actually do something here and try to
continue for a moment what happens if
the Queen's were not traded I'm going to
just play a simple move like g6 stopping
any f5 business yeah and we go from
there what does why do it doesn't really
have any great possibilities you
probably will shuffle go in here going
back and hmm what now King be 135 King
be too yeah you can say okay why does do
nothing but what is what is he supposed
to do you cannot move any of his pawns
who blocked and you're tied to see three
so white is probably shuffling okay here
we go a fire kinky there a form Queen B
2
Queenie form yeah and now it gets very
very serious yeah we can see that Queen
takes b5 is answered by this with a
deadly pin on c2 so what should you do
maybe move the king okay you're getting
hit by be4 yeah and you see this is a
fantastic attack on the king it's not
even just a strategic thing it's just a
great King side attack this is much much
stronger here with them with Queens on
the board then with with queens off the
board yeah note that this is not exactly
hit great great PCM so the timing of the
Queen trade is very often important if
you have the better King position you
should be very reluctant to trade Queens
very often you will do that because you
have something concrete in your favor
winning two pawns winning your piece
that's okay but if you just see a
position that is kind of let's say um
yeah well there's nothing super concrete
going on then keeping the Queen's on
it's usually the right way to do it if
you have to better long-term King safety
yeah I hope you enjoyed this I think it
was very instructive thanks for watching